improve your python skills by building
20 projects
tommy taco has created many popular
python courses on our channel and now he
will teach you how to build these
beginner projects hey guys in this video
we're going to build 20 different python
projects
so this is a list of all the projects
that we're going to build in this video
so we're going to build a lot of
projects like a dash rolling simulator a
quiz program an image analyzer a banner
research program an image resizer and
more as you can see on this list and if
you like more tutorials like this please
don't forget to check out my channel at
codritomi where i teach more on python
and web development in general so
without wasting any time let's get
straight into this video
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
how to send an email with python
now this is not a new concept there are
various ways of doing this but with the
recent update with gmail the security
has been changed so we have to go
through some more security process
before we are able to send a meal with
python but in this tutorial i'm going to
go through every single thing step by
step on what we are going to do
so let's quickly go through the steps in
a comment so this is literally all we
need to do but these are just the most
crucial step number one and two then
once we have the password we'll be able
to come in here and then actually code
what we need to send the mail
so let's go over to chrome
and right here i'm on my account my
google account so what you want to do is
to come into
security
and then security so if i scroll down a
little bit
you see
two-factor authentication so in this
two-factor authentication i already have
it on but what you want to do is to
actually click on that if you have it
off then
it's going to take you through some
self-explanatory process it's going to
ask for
a number or something else that you can
use to you know backup your account but
then once you do all of that that step
is actually done what you need to do
then is to come into this app password
so what you can just do is either go
into your url and type slash app
password
or you can just come here and click it
directly so anyone you want to do is
fine it's going to ask you to log in
again so we're just going to log in back
and now that we log in as you can see i
already have some password created that
i used
sometime
last year
now what we want to do is to actually
select app and in this select app we're
not using any of these
options what we want to click on is this
other and right here we can just say
python for python
and then we're going to generate a code
so it's going to give us a code and what
we want to do is to actually copy all of
that code because it's not going to show
that code to us again so want to copy it
then click on done
so once you have that code copied as you
can see it says created on this time but
it hasn't said when we last used it
because we haven't used that particular
password but once you have that done
that is good those two processes are
already done the next thing we want to
do is to actually go into our file or go
into our program and code this so what
we're going to do now is to come back in
here
and
the first thing we want to do
is to
import email so say from email the
message
import email message
so this email is pre-installed with
python so when you install python on
your computer this email should be there
so once we have that imported let me
actually go through what we're going to
do so we're going to have a variable
that is going to have the email sender
so this is the email that you're sending
from which is the email that we
generated our password for
then you are going to input the password
that we generated now this is not your
email password this is the app password
that we generated
then we are going to input the receiver
so the person that is receiving this
email
and once we've done that we're gonna
specify the subject the body and then
we're gonna
create an instance of this email and
actually send the email so next thing we
want to do is to just have some
variables so we can say email sender
and the email sender has to be code with
tommy gmail.com
and email password
so for this password i'm actually not
going to show the password i copied just
for security reasons so right here i
have this app2 file and i have the
password stored in there so what i'm
just going to do is to actually import
the password from that app to file so
i'm going to say from
up to dot py
import
password
so i have that i have a variable in the
name password so that's what it's going
to do so what we need to do is actually
remove this dot py we just need to say
from app2 because it already knows
there's a python file import password so
now that we have that password i'm just
going to say
password
and once we have that done that is saved
there so
the email password is now the password
that i created so for you just the way
we wrote the password here you just need
to write it there or from a better
security you can just create an
environment variable and store the
password there instead so the next thing
you want to do is to
specify the email receiver
so the person that is receiving this
email and let's leave that blank for now
we're going to come back to do that
and then
let's
the next thing we want to do is to have
the subject
so we're going to say subject
equals to
don't forget
to subscribe
and we're going to have the body so this
is the main body of the email that means
this is what the user is going to read
so we want to have it like this with
three quotes
once we have that we're just going to
write whatever i want to say you say
um
when you watch
a video
please hit subscribe
so once we have that the body is set the
next thing we want to do is to actually
create an instance of this email message
library or package that we imported so
what we're going to do to create that we
can say em
equals email message
so an instance has been created then
we're gonna say em
from
is equals to email sender so this is
saying the person ascending from
and then em
2
is equals to email receiver
and then
em subject
is equals to
the subject
and then we also need to specify the
body but we're going to do that a little
bit different so this one is going to
use something named set content so we're
going to say em dot set content
so the content of the email is the body
so once we have this done this is what
we need the next thing that we want to
do
is to actually come
down here
and we're going to create a context but
for us to create this context we need to
import something named ssl and smtb
library so i'm going to come up here and
then we're going to say
import ssl
and then we also have to import
smtp library
so all of this should be pre-installed
when you install python so you don't
need to run pip install anything they
should already be installed but if they
are not installed then you can just look
up how to install them i'm pretty sure
it's very straightforward
so what we want to do now is to come
here
and say context
ssl dot
create
default context
so this is what we want to use and then
we're going to have with
smtp library
dot smtp
when we say underscore ssl
we're gonna use the gmail smtp so i'm
gonna say smtp.gmail.com
i'm gonna say 465
and the context
is equals to this context right here
that we specified
so context equals context
so once we have that we're going to say
with this
as smtp specifying all of this as smtp
then we're going to say smtp.login
so we want to log in with the email
sender
and the email password which we
specified already
and then we're going to say
smtp dot send mail
now this is when we're actually sending
the mail what this is doing is this is
logging in with those
you know those
this particular credentials that we gave
it and then
once we have been able to login we are
not going to send email so from email
sender
this is the person
that we're sending from
email sender email receiver
sending to and then em dot
as string
so
basically it's converting this em which
is the instance of this email message
that already has all these details now
sent or a string so we want to send all
of this and this should actually work
perfectly but there's one more thing we
need to do is to specify the person that
is receiving the email so for this let's
actually use a temporary email we come
to google and let's just say temp mail
so this tab mail is a site that
generates temporary email for us and
what we can do is just to copy the
temporary email that it generates and
then we're going to use this to test and
once we use it to test we're going to
send the mail to this so if the mail
lands in here successfully damage our
program works
so let's come back in here now and in
the email receiver
i'm going to paste that email in here we
save that
now everything should be working
perfectly
let's run this and see what happens
so that's going to take a while to run
and we don't get any error response so
that means everything should have worked
successfully let's go back and see if
you come here now you can see that it
says from code we told me gmail.com
don't forget to subscribe if we open up
that particular email
and we
read the content
so you can see don't forget to subscribe
when you watch a video please hit
subscribe this is exactly what we
specified here if we close this down
don't forget to subscribe when you watch
a video please hit subscribe so as you
can see this has worked successfully
this is the new way of sending a mail
with python because as i said the old
way is no more working basically so what
we need to do now is to adapt to this
new way so i hope you understood
everything we did in this video let's
quickly go back to
you know talk about what we did first of
all you have to go to your account and
set up the two-factor authentication and
generate the app password then you need
to come here import all the necessary
stuff the first thing you need to import
is this email message so we want to
specify the sender the password the
receiver and the subject then once we
specify all of that we can use that to
create an instance of this email message
we save that as em
then we imported ssl and smtp library
then we use the smtp library to actually
log in and send email
so i hope you understood everything we
did in this tutorial
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
how to build a simple word replacement
program so the reason for showing you
this is to introduce you to the replace
method in python so what this does is
that it takes a string and it replaces
some words in that string with
another word so this is very easy and
straightforward what we just need to do
is to have a new function
let's call that function replace
word
and in there we're going to have a
string
and let's say this string is
i guys
i am tommy
let me say
and i i i i
right and what we're gonna do is to have
a
variable that says was to replace
so this is the word we want to replace
and
let's
collect this from a user
so
let's say
enter the word
to replace
and we also want to have just the normal
word that is going to be replaced so
what this we're going to say enter
the word replacement
so we can just call this
word replacement
and then we're just going to print out
the string right
dot replace so this dot replaces a
method that allows you to replace a word
with another word in a string
so we're just going to say word
to replace we want to replace it with
word replacement so this is all we need
to do
and
what we just need to do now is to call
this function
so let's call this function replace word
so now let's just run this
once we run this it asks us for the word
to replace we say i and enter the word
replacement let's just say a so as you
can see it changes every time we say i
to a says hey guys i am tomian aaa so
that is how to use this basic word
replacement you know method and it
guides you to build you know whatever
you want to build or whatever you think
of but that is how to build a simple
word replacement program
in this tutorial we're going to be
building a simple calculator with python
so what we're going to do is to
first
define the functions so we're going to
first
let's hit
define
the functions
needed
so the functions i'm going to define are
add
sub
more
and div so this is for the addition
subtraction of multiplication and
division
then once we do that we are gonna print
the options to the user so
print options
to the user
so these options will be you know add
subtract multiply or divide or exit so
then once the user inputs
the
option or whatever they want to do let's
say they want to add then we are going
to ask for the numbers
so
ask for values
once we get the values we need then we
are going to use that to call the
functions
once we call the functions
then anything that is done in that
function is going to happen but then
we're also going to add a while loop
to continue
the program
until
the user wants to exit so this is the
steps we're going to follow to build
this program and let's just get started
so i'm going to remove all of this now
as we said we are first going to define
the function so what we want to do is to
say def add
and this is going to take two inputs so
let's say a
and b
and we can just easily return a plus b
but what we can do to make it look
better we can just say answer
is equals to a
plus b
so that is the answer but what we're
going to print to the user we're going
to say print
let's convert
this to string a
then we're going to say plus
so we're using concatenation to like
form a sentence with the
input that user gave us on the answer so
then we're going to say plus
string b
close that
then i'm going to say plus we're going
to open another
and then we're going to say
plus string
converting the answer to a string so
what we're doing here we're just saying
a
plus b
is equals to the answer but we're
converting all of these two strings so
we can be able to concatenate them
there's another way of doing this
instead of using concatenation you can
also use comma like saying something
like
we can just print
a comma b or something like that then we
don't need to you convert it to string
or even use concatenation but we can
just stick with this if we want so once
we have this that is the function needed
to just add two numbers together which
is a very simple basic function then
we're gonna do the same thing for this
subtraction
so we're gonna say
define sub
a
and b
i'm going to say answer
is goes to a
minus b
and then we're going to print exactly
the same thing
and what we're gonna print
is the same thing we printed before a
plus
minus
i'm just gonna do that
concatenate that with string
of b
then we're gonna add that
and then we're gonna say string answer
so we're gonna do the same thing again
for the multiplication
so a
and b
answer
is equals to a
times b
and then we're going to print exactly
the same thing and say string
a
plus
then we're going to use the steric sign
which is also the multiplication sign
and then concatenate
with string b
concatenate
equals to
plus string answer
now for the last function
divide
a and b just like we've been doing i'm
going to say answer
equals to a divided by b and then we're
just going to print
string
of a
concatenate
plus string of b
concatenate
equals to
then concatenate with string
answer
so this is all we need so we have
defined the function successfully the
next thing we want to do is to print out
the options for the user so what we're
going to do now is to print
a
addition
now i'm also going to print
b is subtraction
i'm gonna print c
multiplication
then we're going to print d
division
and then also going to print the last
one so that we will know when to break
out of the while loop exit
and
now we have this what we want to do is
to now have a variable name choice
so this choice
is going to be equals to an input
and that input is gonna be
input
your choice
once the user do that
we're going to say if choice
is equal to
we use the double equals to in python so
if choice is equals to
a
or
choice is equals to
calculator a just if the user decides to
input small letter or capital letter we
got them
so we'll say
let's just print addition
and then
we're going to ask for the input
to input
and then we're going to say input
first
number
but then we have to convert all of this
to an integer because we're dealing with
numbers
and then we're going to do exactly the
same thing for
the second one and say input
and let's just tell them to input second
number
and once we have the two values the user
wants to use to calculate what we're
just going to do is to call the function
add
by giving it these two values so this is
what we just did we
collected the two values from the user
are the two numbers then we call the
function add by giving it these two
numbers which is what is needed here
so once that is done the next thing we
just want to do is to have
another condition by saying
alif
choice
is equals to b
or choice
is equals to calculator b
then we're going to print
subtraction
and a just like we did is equals to
integer
of input
input first number
and b input second number and subtract a
and b
now we're going to do the next one which
is also going to be
because if choice
is equal to c
or choice
is equals to caps letter c
then we want to print
multiplication
and then we also want to collect the
same thing
and
run that function
using the two values and for the last
one we're gonna do
leave choice d or d and then we're just
going to say
print
division collect the two values then use
the function using those two values or
call the function using those two values
so now that we've done that the next
thing we want to do is to say
a leaf choice
is equals to e
or choice
is equals to calculator e
then we're just gonna print
program ended
and what we're just gonna do is to call
the quit function
and stop the program
so once we do that program is ended and
we've got the
quit function so the whole thing should
be working now the whole program should
be working
and we don't need this choice because
that's not the choice we're using so the
old program should be working we define
all the functions show the
options to the user allow the user to
pick what you want collected the values
and encode the function now let's see
what this gives us
so let's say i say b
subtraction
first number is five second number is
two five minus two equals three good
that is what i want
but
as you can see once it gives me the
answer it cuts out of the program what i
want it to do is to keep looping it
until i tell you to exit from the
program so i want to keep calculating
you know multiple numbers until i tell
you to stop
so to do this what we need to do
is to use
a while loop so right here before this
print
let's say wow
true
so while true is gonna do this for us
and we're just gonna put all of this on
the the wow true loop
so
this is just gonna keep looping it
it's not gonna stop until i call this
quit function so everything is gonna
keep going until the user inputs e now
let's
run this and see
so
let me choose c
first number is 4
and second number is 4 gives me 16 and
then asks me to input again so let me
choose a
three five it gives me eight asked me to
input again that is working now if i
click on e
it says program ended and it cuts out of
the program or it breaks the program so
that is working successfully and just
one more thing we might do to you know
make it look better is to add
a break so we're going to have
the slash and n this is just to give it
some spacing so let's add it to all of
the print and the functions
so that when we let me show you quickly
what that does so let me say c
five and five so as you can see there is
a little bit of space here before the
next you know program start running
again just so everything doesn't look
rough
so
that works successfully everything is
working this is the basic calculator
which we built i hope you understand
everything we did in this tutorial and
that is working successfully
in this tutorial we're going to be
building an email slicer
so what an email slicer is it's that it
is a program that takes a particular
email and then slices it into the
username and then the domain
but we are also going to slice it into
username domain and the extension and
the extension is let's say it's at
gmail.com the extensionist.com or just
come so let's do that
before we get started let's walk through
what we're gonna do to achieve this so
the first thing we want to do
is to collect
email from user
so once we have the email what we want
to do next
is to then
slice
or split
the email
using
the
ad
and once we do this basically what this
is saying is that for example let's say
we input
something like
hello
at code
at code with tomi.com if we input this
we're gonna slice the email
i'll split the email using this ads
damage is gonna take this
splitter as one i'm also gonna split
this
as another one
but then once we have this we're gonna
save
the first
part
which is this part which is hello
as the username
and then once we do that
the second part
is gonna
be
let's just save as domain
then what we want to do is now split
this domain so we're going to split
domain
using
the dot so that means this now we're
going to split this kobitomi.com and the
first part is now going to be the domain
which is called we told me and the
second part is going to be this dot com
so what this is saying now is this is
the first part which is the username
that we add already and the second part
from this initial split is called
ritomi.com so what we're not going to do
is now split the second part again using
this dot so then we're gonna have code
with tommy and then we're gonna have
come
so
let's do that real quick
so what we just want to do is to have a
new function and we can just name this
function main
it's not gonna take any input or we're
just gonna we can print something and
say
welcome to
the email slicer
and once we have this
let's just print a blank
sentence or a blank
word so we can have spacing
and then what we want to do after doing
this
is to just collect the email so we can
say email input
is equals to input
i'm going to say input
your email
address
so once you input the email address
we want to do nice to slice it so we're
going to use a particular
format so we're going to say
user
command domain
so let's
send this to user name
so this username command domain once i
split it is this is going to take the
first part and the second part of the
split so this is going to be equals to
email input
dot split
so we're splitting it using
the at
so what this is going to do now is that
once we split it the first part is going
to be goes to this variable and the
second part is going to be close to this
variable so now that we have that
splitted we have the username done we
can print the username but for the
domain let's now say
domain and
extension
so what we want to do now
is to say
domain
dot split
using the full stop so what this is
doing now is updating this domain
with
the
something like this so
hello
at code with
com so now we add this as a domain in
the initial split once we split when we
splitted it using at
so we had code with tommy.com as a
domain but we now want to update the
domain to just be code with tommy and
then the extension should be
come so what we're going to do is domain
equals domain.split using full stop and
then it's just going to do that
so what we can do now is we already have
that those variables and we've given
them their values we can just print this
and we can just say
username
and they just use command service and
concatenation
so we can just say it's username
and we're going to print
domain
this domain
and then we're gonna print
extension
is
extension
so now this should be working let's just
call this
function save this
and run it so now let's see so it says
input your email address now let me use
the
example i've been using all along
hello at codytolmy.com so you can see it
says the username is hello the
domain is called with me and this is the
extension so that works successfully we
can take a little bit further and just
keep you know looping it by saying wow
you know
so we can do
let's quit this
you can do while
true
we can just keep doing this
and once we just run it
so
let's just say something as blank
at gmail.com
so it says blank gmail and that is the
extension and it asks us to input again
so now we can say hello at code with
tommy.com it does that again so this
email slicer is working perfectly and
successfully
in this tutorial we're going to be
looking into banner research in python
so we're going to be writing a program
that performs a binary search operation
using python
so a little bit of explanation a little
bit of context before we get into the
coding part so binary search is a
searching algorithm that works by
repeatedly splitting a set of data in
half till the target value is found
so let me explain what this actually
means
for example what binary search does is
that it takes a list of data a list of
other data
and it takes a target so it keeps
splitting that list of data in half till
it finds that target so for example
let's just say we have
a list that is
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
right and there's our ten
so we have this list
and then what we can do with the binary
search or what binary search does let's
say that we have a target that is
we are looking for three then what he's
going to do is that he's going to split
this data into half so
as you can see what it's going to do is
going to get
the first index and the last index
add it together then divide it by two so
this is zero and this is zero one two
three four five six seven eight nine so
this is nine
then it's going to just drop on zero
plus nine basically something like this
zero plus nine
then it's going to divide down sub by
two
and whatever you get is going to split
that is basically the middle value and
it's gonna use that to split the data
into two so it can split this data into
to from here then that target value
let's say we are looking for three as a
target right
so that mid value that we got let's say
we got a mid value of 4.5 but then it's
just
discards the 0.5 and uses 4 so this is
4 right with an index value of 4.
then it's going to check if 3 is greater
than or less than that 4. since 3 is
less than it is going to discard the
whole list that is after the middle
value so this is going to be deleted and
then it's going to focus on just this
particular list then it's going to do
that again it's going to split it into
half if 3 is greater than that
let's say we get
this is half right since three is equals
to that particular
mid value or middle value it stops the
program because the target has been
found but imagine the target was two
what it's going to do is that it's going
to discard all of this again
from here and then it's going to look
into this particular list then it's
going to run that program again or run
that function again and it's probably
going to see 2 as the value so that's
where banner research works it takes a
list computer you repeatedly split it
into half until it finds the target so
now let's get into the actual coding
part of how we're going to do this
so
if we want to brainstorm this let's
write a few steps which we're going to
take
so
disable that
the first thing we want to do is to
let's just have some comments that says
what we want to do
so we are going to have
a function
that takes
a list
and
let's say
the target parameter
so this is going to collect
lists it's going to collect two
parameters list and a target
and once we have that we're going to
have different variables multiple
variables
and let's say the variables are middle
so we need to know the mid value
the start
value
we need to know the end and the amount
of steps
so in binary search the steps is the
amount of time it has
looked true for the data or it has
splits that set of data into app so
imagine we
after you split that data into our three
times before we get
the particular target that means this
amount of steps gone through is three
steps so we also will have a variable
that tracks that then once we do that
we can either use or recursion we can
either use recursion
or a while loop
to keep because as i said we're going to
repeatedly split that data so we can
either use a while loop but we're using
a while loop that means we're updating
the data by ourself manually
and reviving a recursion we're just
going to call the function inside
yourself again to keep splitting data so
you're going to understand this when we
get more into the coding part
and after this what we are just going to
do
is to
basically increase the steps each time
we step through it so increase
steps
each
time
a split is done
then once we increase the steps this
time the split is done we are now going
to have
some conditions
so conditions too
so we're going to have some conditions
to do something like
if
the target is the middle or if the
target is less than the middle or if
it's greater than the middle then we
want to discard
the other part of the list so conditions
to tag to track
target position
so once we have this
then as i said we're gonna use a while
loop so we're just gonna return
something like minus one to you know
keep
then we're gonna use the while loop that
says something like while the stats is
still less than or equal to the end it's
going to keep looping so let's just
close all of this now and let's just get
straight into the coding
so the first thing we want to do is just
to have a
function
so binary search function so this binary
search function as i said is going to
take
list
and let's say element we can say target
we can say element and if we want to say
and
in here what we want to do
is the same medium
equals to zero so these are the
variables that we are defining now media
is equal to zero start
is equals to zero
the end is asked to be the length
of the list that we are collecting so
this list
and the steps initially is equal to zero
because it doesn't split data yet
so now that we have all of this the next
thing to do is to use a while loop so
we're going to say while
start
is less than or equals to
end so basically we want to keep doing
this until
this for this condition is no longer
true so we say while stat is less than
or equal to end stats is the
we're going to also update the start
this start variable when we split the
whole list but this start is the
beginning of the current list so as long
as that is still less than the end
right we want to continue doing this we
want to continue looping through this
particular code which we're going to do
under here so what we want to do now we
actually want to print something that
shows the user the amount of steps and
like the
let's say the
list that is remaining so like each time
we discard the list or we delete some
part of the list we want to show the
remaining list and the amount of steps
we've done so to do this we're just
going to use a little bit of
concatenation so we'll say steps
step commas steps
just leave a space
and let's say something like
so we're gonna do comma yeah also yes
and we're gonna have list
which is this list
then we're gonna let it start from
the start and end at the end
but we have to add plus one here
so what this is is that we are now
saying
show this list but show it from the
index of start which initially zero and
end which initially is the length of the
string
so let's convert this to a string so
we don't get no errors
so this is what it's going to show so
initially when we run this particular
program it's just going to show us this
list the whole list that we pass into it
because it's just showing us from the
start which is 0 to the end which is the
length of the string but this is for now
because when we update this start as
let's say five let's say this start is
five what it's going to do is that it's
going to start this list from the index
variable five
but for now it's still zero
so once we have this done
let's say steps
now we want to update the step
so we're gonna say steps
equals steps
plus one
and middle
this is one of the most crucial parts so
this is when we're actually splitting
the data into half so start
plus end as i explained earlier we add
the
start and the end and then we divide it
by two
divided by two
then we're gonna say
if
the element
which is the target
value basically
is equals to
list
middle
so if
the middle which is what we got from
here the value we got if that is equals
to the element or the target that we're
looking for then let's just return
middle as the
data found
but if result under container says if
element
is less than list
let me do so that means if it is less
than
the list from the middle what we want to
do
is to update the end
as media
minus one so what are we doing here
basically what we're doing is that we're
saying if this element is less than the
middle list so let me just have a
comment that explains what this is doing
so if element is less than middle list
so what is saying is we have a list
right one two three four five and it's
saying if the element which is let's say
two
let's say elements two obviously the
middle the least middle which is this
particular stuff in this
example is three
so it's saying if element is less than
that so if element which is two that
we're looking for is less than three
then we want to say the end which is now
the end of the new list is equals to the
middle minus one so we want to say the
middle which is three
minus one
and the reason why we did minus one is
because
all indexes start from zero so this will
be zero one 2. so this is now the new
list because the end is now here so
basically it's gonna discard all of this
and create a new list that only has one
two three so that is what this part does
here so when we have the end now updated
once it comes back to the loop again
and in this place the end is now updated
to what to three so it's not gonna be
it's basically not gonna
show the initial list again it's not
gonna show the updated list which has
already cut out some parts that is not
needed
so once
we know about that
the next thing to do is to have like an
so we have a condition right update at
the end that condition is when the
element is less than the middle but what
if it is greater than the middle so then
one says start
is equals to middle
plus one
so just very similarly to very similar
to what this was
this is just saying else that means if
the element is not less than
the medium damage is greater than the
medium then i want to update its start
to middle plus one if i quickly use that
same example
one two three four five
and the value is
let's say four
in this instance so the middle is three
so now that means if the element is
greater than list middle that means if 4
is greater than 3 which obviously it is
greater then this stat is now middle
plus 1 so middle is 3
so we're going to say middle plus 1
the
what we're going to do now is 0 1 2
right then we're going to add 1 to that
that's why we're going to have 0 1 2 3
so from here it's going to discard the
rest of this and it's just going to only
have this particular
list
as a new list
so once we have this done we have
updated all the values that we need the
next thing we want to do
is to just return -1
so we're just going to have something
that say
return
minus one and
this is not part of the loop this is
outside the loop so basically when the
loop is done
so
this is the a very simple like function
to do this very straightforward
and what we can just do nice to actually
test this function and see how well it
is working
so we are gonna
run this function
let's have a list
let's say
my list
is equals to one two three four five six
seven eight nine
and let's say our target
is equals to let's say we are looking
for two
now we can run this particular function
by saying binary search and we're gonna
give it my list
and we're gonna give it target
now when we run this let's see what it
gives us
so as you can see it shows just two
steps
because we are looking for two so it
cuts this this down to this list and the
answer is basically in this list let's
say we're looking for one and let's see
if that will work for us also
so you can see that it shows three steps
now cuts this list down to this list and
he also cuts this list here to give us
one if we're looking for nine it's going
to do the same thing
so let's run that
so it cuts it in three steps and gives
us nine
so let's say we are looking for let's
say we increase this you can test it out
by just you know increasing the values
and do whatever you want to do
and we just have 12
so it still gives us three steps
so as you can see everything here works
successfully we've been able to perform
a binary search using
this
very basic code
there are multiple ways you can actually
code a function to perform a binary
because i said you can use you know a
recursion
which is
uh where you call the function inside
itself so instead of us like basically
using the all of this updating these
values what we're going to do is we're
going to call the function with these
updated values so somewhere like
instead of using the while loop we can
just say after checking if all of this
is true then
we right here where it says less than
and we update this what we can just do
is we just call binary search here again
with the new lists and all of the new
data but
this obviously does the work for us
and
there are various reasons why you
actually want to use binary search
instead of a normal search so the most
important of them is because of the the
time complexity so
if you are using a
let's say a normal set like a linear
search or that which is the normal way
of searching stuff and the linear search
is where it just steps through every
single data in the list until it finds
that value
so as i said the reason why you want to
use binary search instead of
a linear search is because of the time
complexity final research is far more
quicker than
linear search because binary search
doesn't have to look through every
single value in the data or in the list
but for a linear search it has to look
to every single data till it gets to
that particular target we're looking for
for example as we said because we're
looking for two of it just splits this
data and basically cancels all of this
so it doesn't look through that because
you know this the data we're looking for
is normal there then it focuses on where
it thinks it's going to be split all of
this again and you know keep doing that
which saves more time but imagine we're
actually using a linear search so let's
see our linear search is going to work
and we're looking for 12. what we're
going to do is something like 4
i in my list
then we're going to say if
i
is equals to 12
then we'll say print found
now the drawback about this is that it
has to go through every single data so
it's going to count
from one two three four five all the way
till it reaches 12 that's when it's
going to print found so this is going to
take a lot of time and that's why it has
a bad type complexity in this particular
instance so you never want to use
you never want to step through or go
through every single data in the list
instead you just want to use a binary
stage to make everything quicker so i'm
just going to undo all of this and go
back to our code so this is the basic
way of
you know building a program to perform a
binary search
in this tutorial we're going to be
building a quiz program so this is quite
straight forward it's just where we're
going to have a dictionary that contains
a list of like questions and the answers
and then we're going to ask those
questions and answers to the user
and the user is going to answer the
questions
and then we're going to tell the user
the score after and the percentage they
got
so let's quickly go through the steps of
everything we need to do so first of all
let's deactivate that
disable for python so first of all the
first thing that we need to do is to
have
a dictionary
a dictionary that stores
questions
and answers
then what we need to do is to once you
have that dictionary loop through that
dictionary
before we look through the dictionaries
actually have a variable
that tracks
the score
of the
player
then we want to
loop through
the dictionary
using the key
p
key value appears
and once we look through that while
looping through that we just want to
show
this
play
each question
to the user
and allow them
to answer
tell them if they are right
or wrong
then
we want to
show the final result
when
quiz
is completed
so this is the steps we're going to
follow first going to have a dictionary
a python dictionary that stores the
question and answers we can just name
this quiz
then we're going to have a variable that
tracks the scores loop through the
dictionaries and they keep here the key
values pair then display each question
to use and allow them to answer and tell
them if they are right or wrong
and then show the final result let's
actually leave this here and follow
these steps so the first thing we're
going to do is to have this quiz
a dictionary but in this dictionary
let's say the key
is question
one
and
the value is actually gonna be
another dictionary in that so something
like this
yeah
so that is what the value is gonna be so
then the question
is gonna be
let's say
what is
the capital
of france
and let's say the answer
is paris
so that is one question that has all the
questions and answers we need to make
sure we have the comma here so we don't
have any error
so this is one question question one and
it has a value of question and answer
that is one then we're going to go to
the next one make sure you have your
comma
question
two
same thing
question
and then we're gonna say something like
what
is the capital
of germany
and
then i'm just gonna have the answer
and that should be berlin
we're gonna keep going
right here we have our comma
we do question three
we have a question
let's see let's say what
is the capital
of italy
and let's have our answer
as wrong
so just to save time we're gonna copy
and paste this
so let's copy and paste this four more
times
onto
nah
so right here
two three four so right here we're just
gonna change this to four
changes to five
change this to six
changes to seven
and let's say spain
madrid
and let's change that to portugal
lisbon
and then let's say switzerland
burn
and for the last one let's say
austria
you know
so now we have all the list or
dictionary of the questions and in each
of those questions we have the question
and the answer so what we can do now is
to loop troll of this show it to the
user
and then you know continue from there so
before we do that let's see since we
should have a variable that tracks the
score so it is very easy just a score
equals to zero so initially the user has
a score of zero that is all we need to
do for that
then the next thing we need to do is to
loop through but we're going to look
through this especially not the normal
loop because it's a dictionary we want
to look through using the key and the
values
so it says loop three dictionary right
what we're gonna do is to say for
key
value
in quiz
dot items so this way you can look
through a dictionary
what we just want to say is print
the value
so from the value what we want to print
is
the one that the value of the key
question
so we're going to say question
it's going to print that then answer
is going to be equals to
input
answer
so once we say that what we're now going
to do
so we've printed the question and then
we're asking for the answer what we now
want to do is check if this answer is
actually correct so say if answer dot
lower
is equals to value
answer
the lower
then
the user is correct
so let me tell you about using.lower so
basically because python is case
sensitive if we don't use lower what
it's gonna do is that imagine the user
types burn but doesn't
put the capsulator on b let's say the
user types this it's gonna mark it as
wrong but what i'm doing is i'm
converting whatever these are right into
lower case and i'm converting the main
answer also into lowercase so if both of
them are equal then the user is correct
so then we can increase
the score
by one when the user is correct
and after increasing the score
we can print this code to use actually
after every time so let's just do that
so we can say your score
is let's just add
let's convert it to string first of
score
so that is the user score
and
we can just have our else
so if this is not true then that means
the user is wrong
then let's print wrong
then let's actually tell them the
correct answer so say print
the answer
is
then we're going to say
value but now i want to say answer
and let's also print their score so
let's just copy this right here
and that should actually work so let's
see what this is going to do for us
let's save this
and run it
ask us for the capital of france
paris
correct my score is one germany so you
can see now now if i mix let's say
with calculator and small letter
it still tells me i'm correct that's
because of this particular command this
particular condition right here that's
why that is useful
so my score is two imagine
i okay since we already have that we can
test it what i wanted to do is to test
let's say we have all caps imagine big
this is what this is not all caps and
this is all caps if we didn't have this
right here it's gonna say it's false but
because i took care of that it's gonna
say true so i have three so let's start
missing all of it so let's just
so basically
i landed on score of three right
so let's just take it further first of
all everything just look too
packed so what we can just do is to have
a little bit of spacing so right here
where we have score we can just say
print
blank let's also plain blank there and
also right here
print blank
and we'll do the same thing again so we
have that done
what we actually want to do is that
after all of this we want to tell the
user his final score and we also want to
tell them the percentage
so let's say print
i'll say something like you got
string
score
plus
out of seven
of seven
questions
so you got let's say three out of seven
questions correctly
then
let's print out the percentage
and we can say your
percentage
is
concatenation
let's first make sure we're converting
whatever we're doing into string
so we're gonna say score
divided by seven times hundred
to convert it into a percentage
and let's just add by saying let's
concatenate percent just to have the
percentage sign so this should work
let's see
let's quit that and reload it
so let's just get like two out of it
so paris
you can see down now there's spacing so
we can see where
so we've gotten to let's start getting a
little bit wrong so you can see it says
i got two out of seven questions
correctly and my percentage is all of
this this is a
long number what we can just do is to
actually convert this to an integer so
that you know it doesn't show like all
of these decimal points with it
so right here we can just say int and
you actually want to convert it to an
integer before converting it to a string
you don't want to convert it to a string
before converting into an integer
because you can't concatenate an integer
and a string together
but now this should work let's try it
out and see so i'm just gonna get let's
say three out of it
we have france paris
germany berlin
rome
so as you can see it says i got three
out of seven correctly and the
percentage is 42
so that is how to actually build like a
very basic
quiz app or quiz program with python as
you can see that was very easy to build
didn't take a lot of time and i hope you
understood what we did to this point
in this tutorial i'm going to be showing
you how to
convert a text or a link to a qr code
using python
so this is very easy because there are a
lot of libraries out there that already
allows us to do this so let me just walk
you through the steps on what we're
going to do
so the first thing we want to do is to
install
all the libraries needed
once we install the libraries needed
then we are going to
create a function
that collects
the text
and converts
it to
a qr code
then we're gonna save the qr code
as an image
once we save the qr code as an image
then we are going to run the function
basically
so this is the basic steps that we're
going to take and let's just go ahead
and do this
so the first thing we want to do let's
first open up a new terminal and let's
install the packages needed so i'm on a
mac so i'm going to use pip 3 to install
if you're under windows you don't need
to use p3 just type pip and i'm going to
say install
qr code and image so i need these two
libraries
so what i'm gonna do is to install qr
code and image i already have them
installed so as you can see it says
requirement already satisfied but for
you it should go ahead and install that
so once i have that done i'm only gonna
import qr code i don't need to import
image
once i have that imported let me just
have a new
function and say generate qr code
and it's gonna take a text or url or
whatever you want it to take
and then what we want to do is to say qr
is equals to qr code
dot
qr code
and version
is equals to
one
and
error
underscore correction
is equals to qr code
dot constant
dot error
underscore
correct
underscore l
and box size
is equals to 10
and let's say border should be like
five
oh let's leave here four and that is
done the next thing we just want to do
is to add the data to this qr so this is
like going to generate a new qr code but
what we now want to do is to add
this text or the url whatever the user
inputs we want to add it into this qr
code that we just generated so let's
come here and add
full stop to avoid the error
and then we're just going to say qr dot
add data so this is just going to add
the data first
i'm going to say text
and qr make
let's make it fit
so fit equals true
and
image
should be equals to qr
the make image
so this is going to make the whole image
of the qr code with the data and
everything so i want to fill it with the
color of black you can input whatever
color you want
and the back color should be white
so as you know most qr code
has
this particular format white and black
and then let's just save this image so
we're going to say image.save
and let's name it something like
qr
image
dot png
now this is working perfectly what we
just want to do now
is to run the function so we can say
generate
qr code
and let's give it a text i'm gonna give
it a link so let me say
https
www.codewithtomy.com
and now once i run this this is gonna
create a qr code based on this
particular
format and it's going to give you this
data which is called vitomi.com so let's
run this
so it says
it has no attribute
error so we just need to come here and
change that to error that was a
typographical error so let's save that
and run it again
we don't have no response but if we go
into our computer right here
so i am in just in my root directory and
it's as you can see i have this qr code
named qr image
so that is the qr code that has been
generated or that has been generated
based on this format or based on this
text this url so if i scan this qr code
it's going to give me this particular
url that i used but let's take it
further and say we want to ask the user
to input their own url then we generate
the qr code based on the url so we're
just going to say
url
equals to input
we're going to ask the user
enter
your url then once they enter that
we're just gonna generate this based on
the url so let's save the let's say this
is zero zero one
let's just run this
now once we input let's say https
youtube.com slash code
with tommy
no response but if i come in here
you can see that i have a new code
different formats it looks different
from the initial one once i scan this
you can scan this using your phone or
just scan it online or anything it's
going to take you to the site which we
input which was youtube.com code with
tommy so that is how to create a basic
qr code generator
there are very there are various ways
you can use this you can use it on your
website to you know do multiple things
just automatically convert particular
text to qr code for your users there are
a bunch of ways you can use this and
that is how to build it
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
how to build an interest rate monthly
payment calculator so it's a program
that is going to take the input of
you know the principal amount borrowed
the
unwanted interest rate and the amount of
years and then it's going to tell you
how much you're going to pay
each month for the total amount of years
till you pay off the loan back
so before we get started let me walk you
through the steps of what we're going to
do so the first thing we want to do is
to
collect
the
necessary
input
and this uh the principle
and this principle is the initial amount
borrowed or the amount
the loan amount and apr which is
the annual interest rate and then the
years so this is the amount of years
that
the
that you're going to use to pay the loan
back basically so once we collect those
inputs what we're going to do is then
calculate
we're going to calculate the monthly
payment
and we're just going to show that to the
user
so this is all we need to do to be
honest this is where the main work is
calculating that monthly payment and i'm
going to walk you through it step by
step so let's just get straight into
this
so
let's just create a function
so we create a main function it's not
going to take any input
what we can just do we can print
something and say
this is
a monthly
payment
loan calculator
so once that is done we can print let's
just print
this to
give some spacing
and then we want to get the input from
the user so the principle
and note that for this type of
calculation since we're dealing with
money we have to use float
so we have to convert this to float
so let's have an input and say
input
the loan
amount and one of the apr
which is
the annual interest rate
so input the annual
interest
rate
and then this should be a float
and the amount of years
this should just be an integer
and we say input
and let's say input
amount
of years
so once we have those inputs we can go
straight to the next step which is
calculating the monthly payment this is
the payment which you pay monthly till
you paid it on back so let's say monthly
interest rate
so we can say apr we have to divide this
api by 1200 so this api reaches the
unknown interest will be divided by 1200
first so that's to get the rate
then we're gonna
save months
equals to the amount of years which we
collected multiplied by 12
so just to calculate the amount of month
which is going to be used to pay this
loan back then we can calculate the
monthly payment
so we can say monthly payment
equals to let's change this to let's say
amount
of
months and monthly payments can be equal
to principal
multiplied
by the monthly interest rate
then we divide this
by i think we should open a bracket here
should we yes we should and we say one
minus then we open another bracket
so we're basically using body mass right
here
one
plus
monthly
interest rate
that's inside that bracket then outside
that we multiply it
you will use the asterisk sign twice and
then we say minus
amount of month
so this is going to do the work for us
and then we're just going to display the
result to the user basically so we can
just say print
the
monthly
payment
for this loan
is
this is concatenation and let's say
monthly payment
so this should work fine
before we run this let's say main
so all of this should be working now
let's test it out and let's see
so let's say the loan is twenty thousand
with a rate of three percent
and input amount let's say five years
so it says can only concatenate string
no float so what we just need to do is
to change this to a string
and then
let's run that again
twenty thousand
three and five
so it says the monthly payment for this
loan is 359.3738
and all of that so let's just make this
look more presentable let's cut it to
only two decimal points because that's
what money ends up to decimal points
so to do this we are not going to need
to convert this to string no more let's
remove this
and we're also not going to use this
right here so let's remove this
what we want to do
we're actually going to use a particular
format by saying
percentage
dot 2f so the 2f what it does it cuts
it cuts this
to 2 decimal places
and then we're just going to say
percentage
and that should do the work
so let's save it
run it
twenty thousand now
three percent five years so you say
359.37
so if you want to use dollar sign pounds
whatever you can just add it right there
by saying
dollars whatever you want to add so this
does the work for us and everything is
working fine as you can see so what we
can also do is to just use a while loop
to you know keep looping this onto the
user doesn't want to calculate anything
normal but you can do that if you want
to do that so let's run this again and
see what it does let's try with like a
larger amount to
million
and with a rate of
a crazy rate let's say 40
and two years yeah so that's gonna be
122 000
every single month
so this is how to build a basic
interest rate calculator so as you can
see what it did we took the input we
calculated the monthly interest rate and
then we calculated the monthly payments
and we just printed that to the user
so this is how to do that
in this tutorial we're going to be
building a random password generator
program
so
let's outline everything we're going to
do to build this
so the first thing we want to do is to
ask the user
if they want to generate a password
or not
then once we ask them if they want to
generate a password
if they say yes
so if yes
yeah so if yes
we don't want to generate the password
yet we want to ask for the password
length so if yes
ask for password
length
and once we ask for the password length
what we just want to do is to generate a
password so we just generate the
password and then print the password
so once we print the password that
program is done but if they say no then
we want to exit the program so
if
if initial response
is no
exit program
so this is the outline we're going to
follow and we're gonna get you to do
more coding stuff in a bit so this is
what we're gonna do we're first gonna
ask
ask the user if they wanna generate a
password or not once they say yes then
we're gonna write a function that's
gonna generate our password in that
function we're gonna ask for the
password length and then we're just
going to generate the person and print
it to the user so let's just go ahead
and do that so let's clear this up
so the first thing we want to import a
string
and then we want to import random
once we import both of these
the next thing we want to do is to
have a variable named characters
so what this characters is going to do
is that it's going to take
the
basically a list of all the different
characters that we want to generate our
password from so this is going to be
a string dot
dot ascii
let us
i also want to use to string the digit
and let's actually add one more we want
to use some
random signs yeah like these signs
so we also want to use all of these
signs right here
and this should actually be a list so we
want to say list of all of this
so i converted that to a list
so this is basically the amount not the
amount of characters basically the
characters we want to generate the
password from so when is generating
password in my peak let's say two
characters from here three characters
for me and one character from here it
depends so that's going to be random now
we want to have our function that says
generate
password
and now that we generate the password
we're gonna say
password length
is equals to an integer
and let's say how long would you like
your password to be
so that is a
the question we're going to ask the user
and whatever the user input we're going
to convert that to an integer
so now that we
you know have that what we want to do is
to shuffle this character so it's not
just going to be
like
let's say it's not just going to pick
two from here then three from here then
one from here like
in order we just want to shuffle it so
it takes it randomly so what we're gonna
do is to say
random dot shuffle
characters
so once we shuffled our character that
is done
the next thing we want to do
is to say
let's first have the password as an
empty list
so once we do that we want to pick
random characters now from this
from the list so what we're going to do
is now use a for loop and say
for
x in range
of password length
so what we're going to do is to say
password
which is this password
dot append
random
dot choice
so it's going to take you randomly from
the characters
so once it takes it from the characters
randomly now we want to shuffle the
password so we're going to say random
dot shuffle
password
so the password that we just got you
know is appending
characters from this list right into
this password list
then once we have that we also want to
shuffle it again just to make it more
random and what we're just going to do
is to now convert this list because we
want it to be a string but right now we
initialize it as a
as a list so what we're just going to do
we're going to say print
we're gonna say password
is equals to
blank
dot join
password
once we do this now we can print
password now we want to print the
final password to the user so we're
going to say print password
so now we printed that
what we're just going to do we have the
generate password working we have the
function should be working right now so
now
we're just going to run the part the
program normally and we're going to say
we're actually going to ask the user
so we're going to say
option
is equals to
input
do you want to generate
a password
then we're gonna say yes
or no
so that is what we need then we're gonna
say if
option
is equals to yes
then we're gonna run the generate
password function which we just did
right here
but if option is
equal to no
so we're going to say
alif
option
is equals to no
then we're gonna say
let's print something like
program
ended
and we're gonna run the quit function
so that's gonna quit our program but
then if it's something else
we're just gonna print
invalid input
input
please
input yes
or no
and we are gonna
quit the program
so
this should be working now everything
should be working fine let's save this
code
and then let's run it and see what it
gives us
so you ask us do you want to generate a
password i'm going to say yes okay let's
first change that that is a bit
together so it should be something yeah
like this yeah that should be all right
now let's save it
and run it again so now do you want to
print the password and say yes how long
would i like the password to be let's
say 17
and then it prints a random password of
17 letters so let's run that again
you say yes
and i want the password to be let's say
191 it's going to print a long password
of 191 characters
now let's run it for the last time and
test if we say no
so once we say no
it says program ended
which is what we want and let's test if
we write something else so let's just
write a random stuff and it says invalid
input please input yes or no
so that is a very easy simple way on how
to generate random passwords using
python you can integrate this let's say
you you learnt how to build a web app
with jungle or flask or something or
python framework and then you want like
when a user is trying to register you
want to have a feature that just allows
them to generate a password for them you
can input this type of you know logic or
this type of program in there and it's
just going to generate a password for
your users so this is a very simple
project on how to generate random
password
in this tutorial we're going to build a
dice rolling simulator program so what
this is going to do is that it's just
going to ask if we want to roll the dice
then once we say yes it's actually gonna
like simulate rolling a dice and it's
gonna
print out two different numbers ranging
from one to six and it's also gonna show
us like a drawing of those numbers so
let me show you what this actually looks
like before we get into coding it so
this is the program right and it says
row dice if i say yes
you can see that it says dice road at
four and three and it shows me the dice
four and three if i say yes again
it wrote five on one it shows me five on
one i say yes again
it wrote two and four it showed me the
dice drawing of two and four so let's
get straight into this first of all
let's make this a little bit less
now the first thing that we actually
want to do is just to you know
let's walk through the steps we're going
to use random so we're going to have to
import random
then once we import random we're going
to
define
a function
to roll the dice
so once we define that function to roll
the dice the next thing we want to do is
to
like have a
kind of like a dictionary so
create a dictionary
a dictionary that
basically we
will have the drawings
of the dice
so this dictionary is going to hold like
all the drawings of the dice and
everything we need
and then we're just going to get into
using a while loop asking the user for
what you know if they want to continue
and all of that let's just collapse this
and get straight into it
so as i said the first thing i want to
do is to import random
once we have random imported then we're
going to have a function named row
dice
and in this function
so what we want to do in here
is that we want to ask the user so we
can say
row
equals input
and then we'll say something like
row dice yes or no so let's just
deactivate this real quick
so once we say row dies yes or no
let's actually change this to yes
or no
and we're going to ask this out to input
if it wants to roll the dice so we're
going to say while
row
the lower
is equals to yes
the lower
so the reason why i do this
road or lower and yes to lower is
because if the user inputs yes with all
cap letters or all small letters or a
mixture of calculators and small letters
it's still going to see it as the user
saying yes
so we're just going to say dice 1
is equals to random
dot random
that's rand int so the random integer
between 1 and 6. so it's going to
generate a random integer between one
and six so we say dice two
generate another random integer
between one and six also
so once it generates that what we're
gonna do is print
dice road
and then we're just going to say
this and this so this is going to hold
let's say two and three four and five
whatever was wrote then let's format it
the format
and let's just format it to have
dice 1
and dice 2.
so once we have this what we can just do
we can then ask the user if he wants to
roll again so say
row equals input
then now instead of saying
row dice we just roll again
so yes
or no
and then organize the user for that
so what we just want to do now is to run
this particular
function
so this should work perfectly let's see
so let's quit this tab and run it again
so yes we want to roll the dice so it
says say six and four road
yes six and two
six and one quite lucky three and six
one on one so you can see that that is
working the next thing on the final
thing we want to add is to just add the
drawings so we want to actually have
like images or drawings of the
particular number that has been rolled
so to do this what we're going to do is
to come
we're actually going to come all the way
up here
so what we're going to do is to just say
well i'm going to paste up like a block
of code now this code is going to have
all the drawings so what i'm going to do
is come in here
and just paste so as you can see this is
like
it just it's basically a dictionary
right it has a key and the value has
like this topo but in each of the topo
has like values that forms this square
type shape that has each of the values
for
drawing one two three four five and six
so
you can just take you know all of this
right
here so that is how that looks like
so once you know you have this
everything is basically done you just
need to know the name of this particular
dictionary so once you know the name of
that dictionary the next thing you want
to do is to then go down into the code
where we are printing the values that
were wrote so down here we just want to
print
let's see let's leave a space first of
all something like this
and let's just say dot join
dice drawing
the one that has in the x key not index
this time around key of that is one
we'll do the same thing for dice two and
let's see what it gives us so this
should work
perfectly so yes we want a row
so you see it says five and four it's
prints five and four we wanna roll again
five on one it prints five on one we
wanna roll again one and six it prints
one and six now let's say no it's cut
out so it breaks out of that program so
that is how to basically build a dice
rolling
system or dice rolling simulator
in this tutorial we are going to be
building a site connectivity checker
so what this is going to do is that
we're going to give it a url or a
particular link and it's going to check
the
main the status of that site basically
so if the site is up and running if you
can access that site or if the site is
down it's going to give us an error so
once we give it the link or the url it's
going to give us a response if the site
is up and running and everything is
working it's going to give us a response
of 200 and
some other response if there's an error
or something
so let's just get straight into this we
need uh to import a library that we're
going to use and this library is called
url leave so this should be installed
when you have python installed it should
be pre-installed it's python already but
if it's not installed you can just type
pip install url lib and that should
install it for you so let's go ahead
and write the steps of what we're gonna
do so this is quite easy and
straightforward the first thing is just
to import url lib
once we have that imported
we're going to use a particular
subset of that url leave code request so
i'm going to use
url lib
dot request
yeah to get the data from the url that's
exactly what we want to do then once we
do that the next thing we want to do is
just write a function
a function
that
takes a url
and then
returns
a response
so this is all we want to do
let's disable that so this is all we
want to do and it should be very
straightforward it's actually very easy
to you know to code because the library
already has what we wanted to do for us
so let's just follow these steps so
let's import
url lib
so this url leave that we're importing
we're not just using it directly as i
said we're going to use dot request
so we're just going to import url
request and let's import it as url
so that when we're using it we don't
need to write url lib.request we just
say url lib
and
what we want to do now is to have a
function called main
so this function let's say it collects a
url
so in here we can just print something
like
this is a site
connectivity
check our program
and then we can just
print to
input the url
of the site
but actually
we i think we even want to you know tell
the user to input the url before
running this particular command so what
i want to do is to come here
i want to take all of this here
and put it here instead so what this is
going to do is that it's going to print
this and tell the user to input the url
of the site
so what we can just do
is that we can just say
url
input url
is equals to input
and then we can just have this right
here so input the url of the site
you want to check
and this is going to input the url for
us i'm just going to collect the url for
us then what we're going to do now is
we can say dev main
what we can now do is
since we already know we have the url
we're going to take the url
let's just say
url equals url that doesn't really make
any difference since we already have url
being sent in here so let's just leave
that like that and what we're just going
to do now we can just do something like
print
check-in
connectivity
and then we can say
url lib
dot open
dot url open
so we want to open up this url
but then we want to store whatever is
gotten here in a response so
we'll store it in a response variable
and this is basically all we need and we
can just print something like let's say
connected
to
url
successfully
that is all we need and then we want to
show the response like is he a response
of 200 you see an error
so let's just say print
the response
code
was
response
dot get code so this dot get code is
going to allow us to get the code
or the response code basically and as i
say 200 it means that it got it
successfully or was able to use that
site successfully so this is basically
all we need right now but the only thing
i see that we need to change is that we
need to have this particular function
above
all of this so we need to write the
function of s and this is because
once the user inputs this url right the
next thing we want to do is to call this
url on diet now is to call this function
on that is using the url that the user
wrote but in python everything is step
by step so we can call a function that
is below
our code so imagine i call the function
main here
that's impossible as you can see it
gives us an error that it can recognize
that particular function and this is
because python looks up not down
so once i call this function it looks
for this function
from the code above it since it doesn't
find that it doesn't see it as a
function in this code even though we
still have the function right here but
it doesn't see it so what we need to do
is to make sure that the function
is above the code well above where we
are calling it from
then that will work so what we just want
to do let's remove this from here we can
take all of this function
we can cut it out then right here after
importing we can just paste that
now everything should be working
successfully so if i now say let's say i
run
so let's say i run this and i say
main and i give it the input url that
the user input this right here
so right here i'm just going to say
input
url
so once i give it this now
everything should work successfully
because it's going to go up and look for
this main your this main function is
gonna give you this input url which the
user
entered and then it's gonna you know
open it save it in the response and
print the response code so that is all
we need and as you can see right here it
didn't give us that error that
it can't find the function that is
because the function now is above it so
that is also a good tip to know in
python so let's save this file and let's
run it
so it says this is a site connectivity
checker program input the url of the
site you want to check so let's just
check google
say www.google.com
so you see it says checking connectivity
connected to
google.com successfully the response was
200 now 200 means it was able to access
that url or that link
let's run it again let's say
let me check my site
so my site is up and running let's see
if it's also going to give us 200
codytomy.com
as you can see it says connected
successfully the response was 200.
so that
particular one worked successfully
so
everything we did here is very easy and
very straightforward we just used the
library and we just allowed user to
input it and input the link and then we
gave the user a response so i hope you
understood what we did
in this tutorial
in this tutorial we're going to be
building a currency converter program so
this is very easy and you know very
straightforward what we just need to do
is to first of all have a function that
is called main and this function we're
just gonna you know say this is a
program that converts let's say us
dollars to you know group great
britain's pounds and then we're going to
collect the
let's say we're going to ask a user for
the amount of dollars they want to
convert then we're going to run a
function named convert to pounds
then we're going to show the user the
answer and under that we're going to
also going to have to have another
function we're actually going to use a
lambda function to you know have this
particular
converter and i'm going to show you what
we're going to do so let's get straight
to it
so we're going to say def main
and what we want to do is print
this program converts
us dollars
to pounds
sterling
and let's just have another print so
that there will be some spacing
so print
and dollars
will be equals to input
enter amount
in dollars
and we have to evaluate this so we have
to wrap it with the evaluate
and once we do that we're gonna say
pounds will be equals to convert
to
pounds and we're gonna give it dollars
so once we have that we're going to
print
that is
and let's say
pounds
so what we're going to do now is that is
we just want to print the equivalent in
pounds so that is pounds
i'm going to have the comma
and say pounds in here
so this should do the work first
but as you can see it says that it
doesn't see any function named convert
to pounds so what we're just going to do
down here is to come here
and create a new function named convert
pounds
equals lambda
dollars
so dollars
by
so we need to check the exchange rate so
if we come to google you can see that
the current exchange rate is no point 82
pounds sterling so we're going to say
multiplied by 9.82
and that should actually do the work for
us so now if we call main
everything should work well right here
we need to have lambda
so now everything is working perfectly
if we run this this should actually work
now let's save and see
input the amount in dollars let's say
500
so it says convert to pounds is not
defined
so this is because right here there is
no n so that should work now
now let's run it again
and save 500
so you can see it says that it's 410
pounds let's run it and let's say
something like
750 dollars 615 pounds let's come back
here and you know check that 750
so you can see 614.14
you know i think it wrapped it up to you
know 615 pounds so that is how to build
a very easy and simple currency
converter of course if you want to like
scale this or like actually build a
big application from this what you need
to do is to like
probably have an api that gets all the
rate like this type of rate then you
should do something like you're going to
ask the user what the two different
currencies they want to convert to then
when you have all of that you know what
function to call you know what rates to
use and all of that but for now this is
just a basic you know
way of doing this type of application
in this tutorial we're going to be
building a very simple program that
tells if a particular year is a leap
year or not
now to do this is
quite easy and straightforward what we
just need to do is to have a new
function and this is going to be
something like is leap year
and it's gonna take
the parameter
and it's just gonna say if here
percentage the percentage sign should be
here if your percentage four
is equals to zero
numbers if the remainder of the year
divided by four is zero
then we're going to say
it should be a leap year but we also
have to have another condition but
before we have that condition let's
first have our else statement for now
let's pass
say else print
not sleep here
so basically what this is saying is that
if you have percentage 4 which is the
remainder of 4 is not equal to 0 then
it's not a leap year so yeah when we say
pass what we want to do is just have
another condition so we're going to say
if
yeah
mod
100
is equals to zero
then we're gonna do something
well
else
just print slip here
so right here we just want to print slip
here let's change this real quick
so this is a leap year then right here
where we pass what we want to do is have
another
nested
condition and just say if yeah
mod 400
is equal to zero
then that should be a leap year
so we're just gonna print leap year
else it's not a leap year
so this is a very basic program that
does this as you can see just this
function alone should be able to you
know do the work what we can just do now
is to run this so say is leap year
and let's give it something like two
thousand
so let's quickly go about what is
actually gonna do so
this is saying if
year mode four is equal to zero
then we're going to check if
the m mode android is equal to zero and
we're also going to have to check again
if year mode 400 equals to zero then is
a leap year so but initially if it's not
even equal to zero
it's not a leap year right here also if
year mod hundred is not equals to zero
it is a leap year but if is equals to
zero and then
mode 400 is equal to zero also then it's
a leap year else it's not a leap year so
if you actually do the calculations
manually you'll see that it adds up
so 2000 was a leap year let's save it
and see what it says so as you can see
it says leap year what we just want to
do is to come in here so right here i
have a list of leap years
2000 2004 so leap years basically every
four years right so what we can just do
is you know change this and say 2024
and that's your print leap year 2020
also should print leap year
right but let's try for something that
is not elite p let's say 2013
you can see is not a leap year
let's say 20
51
that is not a leap year so that is a
the way to build a program that tells
you the year is a leap year or not
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
how to build a simple word dictionary
using python so this is going to be a
program where we're going to have a
basic dictionary that has
a key value of a word and the definition
of that word
then we're going to be able to ask the
user to input a word and then from the
dictionary that we have we are going to
get the meaning or the definition of
that word so let me walk you through the
steps of what we're going to do
so first of all we're gonna
have a python dictionary
that has
a key value
pair
that represents
a word and its definition
so once we have that the next thing we
are going to do is to
collect
input from
the user so this input is going to be
is the word
is a word basically
and then we are going to check
if the word
is in the dictionary
and print
the definition
so this is the basic steps that you are
going to take
let's just get started
so we cancel of that
the first thing let's just have a
function named main
and in this function
we're going to have a word dictionary so
let's name this word
dictionary
so we're actually using a python
dictionary right to store
all the values so what we're going to do
is to say equals to
and let's say we have a word named i
and we say
a way
of
greeting
let's just say we have another word that
says ice
and let's say an organ
for scene
yeah let's just have those two words
basically
and we
okay let's add one more just to give it
let's say
f
and let's say a planet
in space
cool so we have this let's make sure we
have our comma right after every single
key value pair so once we have this the
next thing we want to do
is to collect the word from the user so
we say word
is equals to input
enter a word
and we can say
let's say something like
we can just say if the word is blank we
want to break or we can just go straight
to it so let's just say something like
if word
is equal to blank
then we kind of tell the user to input
it again now let's just break
we can do that and we say if
word
in
word dictionary
so that means if this word is inside
this work d what dictionary then what we
want to do is to print
the word
then we're going to print
the word definition
so i'm just going to say a word
dictionary
of that word
so this is gonna do it for us
but this break basically when we say
break that means we're breaking out of a
loop so the reason why i put this break
here is because we're actually gonna
write a while loop here so that the user
can keep asking for a word till he
doesn't want to ask for it again so
let's say while
true
so while this is true
all of this should be under this and
distributing small letters so this
should now work perfectly
so let's run this
let's see what it does
so entire what if we enter i so it says
i a way of greeting
if we enter f
f a planet in space winter ice
eyes and organ for scene and you see
that once i enter nothing and i click
enter it breaks out of that program
so this is how you can be the basic
you know what dictionary but you would
have already seen a problem with this
there is no way we can actually write
all the
words in english and their definition in
just a basic python dictionary so you
see that let's say you have a file an
external file that you can import that
has
all the text and you know
from the synonyms and
the definition
or you can just use a python library so
there are there is a python library that
someone has already worked on that you
can just install on your computer and
you know that has all this data that you
need and you can just use that in your
program
so to take this a little bit further and
show you how to actually build the
working dictionary that you can actually
use we're going to use the diction
library named pi dictionary
so what i'm going to do now i'm actually
going to
clear all of this up okay no i'm not
going to clear this up but i'm going to
open a new terminal so let's come here
and click new terminal
we want to install pi dictionary
so if you're on a mark type pip3
if you're on a window just type pip
so install
pi
dictionary
so i already have it installed so it's
saying recommend already satisfied but
for you it should go ahead and solder
so let's close up this terminal now that
we know we have that the first thing we
want to do
is to import this pi dictionary so i'm
going to scroll up here i'm going to say
from pi dictionary
import pi dictionary
so once i have this i'm going to
define an instance of this by
dictionaries i'm going to say dictionary
equals to pi
dictionary
with the parenthesis
and once we have that what we can just
do right here so
we're gonna say
we don't even need all of this
we don't need to put in a function no
more what we can just do is to say
let's collect a word from a user so
let's say
let's just first test this and see what
it gives us so let's say print
dictionary
dot meaning
and let's say something like ice
once we run this
you can see that it prints this
right here and it says noun
the organ of sight
good this it basically gives you
different definitions so different noun
definitions of ice right here you can
also see that gives you different
definitions different verb definitions
that's what that can do and you can do a
bunch of stuff you can translate a word
from you know one
one word one language to another it's
gonna give you signal names antonyms and
more so
you can explore that more if you wanna
see but for now let's just stick with
this so what we can just do nice to ask
the user for what he wants to import so
what he wants to get the definition of
so
we say input
enter
your word
then we can say
print
dictionary.meaning of word
now let's see this
now let's say
ice again
and now we can input our word and we get
the meaning of that word
so we can also you know
have a while loop
while true and all of this
should be on diet
and once
we have that it's going to keep looping
but what if we want to break it so what
we can do is if
word
is equals to blank
then we want to break out of it
so
that's all we need but then just print
the meaning of word so if it's blank
it's gonna break out of it before even
runs this so we're cool
now let's try to run this and see
so let's have another word like
let's say indentation
and as you can see it gives me the
meaning
and that's what we need now let's run it
again and just not input anything it
breaks out of it
so you can see that the library is quite
efficient it has everything you already
need so you don't need to start writing
all the words in english and the
definitions because that's gonna take a
long time for d2 result
so another thing we can do is to
actually give this library like a bunch
of words and it's gonna give you the
meaning of those words
in let's say a list or even a dictionary
format
so let me show you what i'm talking
about
so we can remove this
and what we can do is right here where
we are initializing this we can just
give it the words immediately so let's
say we give it ice
and we give it indentation
and let's say we give it
so we give you all of these words what
we can just do now is to print
dictionary
dot
dot
print meanings
so this is going to print the meaning of
everything for us and this is going to
print
once we run
so
as you can see we it gets all the
meaning
so we say i it shows us the meaning in
nouns
it has different meanings and also for
verbs then for the next one indentation
and for the next one
ed so it gives us everything we need but
let's say as you can see this is just a
plain text and there's no way we can
actually use this
like in our code but what we can just do
is to
allow it to return us the definition but
in a dictionary format in a python
dictionary format so then we can you
know have key value pairs that we can
actually use
or print in our program so instead of
print meanings what we just want to say
is get a minute
so once i save this and run it
you're gonna see now that we have this
but in a python dictionary format so
exactly the same thing but now we can
use this anyhow we want since it's a
dictionary format and python understand
dictionaries so we can you know just get
let's say we just want to get
just this definition or just this
definition we can actually get it
because it is in a recognizable data
structure in python so
that is the best way to go about it if
you have multiple words that you want to
print
so that is how to
build a simple dictionary in python a
simple word dictionary in python i hope
you understand everything we did till
this point
we're going to be taking our python
knowledge and using you to build a
simple game of rock paper scissors so
the first thing we want to do is to
import random so we're just importing
this down because we're gonna use it
later
and you want to have a list that
contains the options
so the options are rock paper and
scissors
and i'm going to ask for the user input
and the user input is going to be input
choose rock paper scissors
the computer input is going to be
randomly chosen from one of these three
lists so
i'm
gonna say computer
let's go input
random dot choice options
and
in here we want to change something i
want to add something we're going to say
rock paper scissors
or exit
so if the user
types rock paper scissors is going to
keep playing the game every time x8 is
just going to opt out of the game
and want to have exit as a boolean which
is going to be false
so this exits is we're going to have
like a while loop and we're going to say
while exit is false then we want to keep
playing the game but if the user then
types exit we're going to change exit to
true so that means he wants to opt out
of the game so actually what we're going
to do
we're going to actually have
exit on top
and then all of this should be in like a
while loop so while exit
is equals to false
equals to false then we want to keep
doing all of this so this should have an
indentation
so while exit is equal to false let's
just say
now we're going to say if user
input is equal to exit
then we're going to print
game ended
and then we're going to set exit equals
to true so now that exit is set into
true if the user input exit this whole
program is just going to stop
but these are those input exits and
let's say the user says if user input
is equals to rock
so if user
input is equal to rock
then we're going to check if computer
input
input
is equals to
rock also
so if user inputs rock and computer
inputs rod
then we're gonna print
your input
is rock
and we're also going to print computer
input is drug
and it's a tie
so if user input drop computer input
rock that is a tie
and
let's have an else if statement
and say if computer input
is equals to paper
then we're going to print these three
things also but we're going to change
some stuff so we're going to print
your input is copy your input is rug but
computer input is paper
and
obviously
the computer wins
when the computer is we want to add one
point to the score of the computer so
what we actually need to do is to come
up here and have
a user point
and then we want to have computer points
equals to zero so what we're going to do
when the computer wins we're going to
say computer
points
it should be point
and then
computer points
say plus equals one by increasing the
computer points by one
and
we're gonna do the same thing again by
saying
if the computer now inputs scissors
then we want to say your input is rock
the computer input scissors
then you win
and then we're gonna
say user
point plus equals one
so this is the basic
logic of what we're gonna use to build
this program
and then we're gonna continue by saying
in here we're gonna have
and else if
but this time around it should be if the
user input is different
so let's say the user input is equals to
like paper
then we're going to do all of this
so i'm just going to copy this paste it
in there
and then we're going to check if
computer input is rock so you input
paper
computer input rock
then you win
so when you win
we increase your score by one
and then computer input
is paper
and then your input is also paper
then we're going to say it's a tie
so one is a tie we don't input we don't
increase any score so we're going to
remove this
and now computer input is paper so
we're going to say
your input is paper
computer input is scissors
then computer wins
so we improve computers points by that
we're going to do the same thing again
but this time around for when
user input scissors
so now if the computer input rock we're
going to say your input is scissors
computer input rock
computer wins
so we're increasing computer points
by one
and we're gonna do the same thing
your input is scissors
computer input is paper
and then
we're gonna say
is you win
is our point plus equals one
and
right here your input to scissors
it's a tie
and one is a tie as we know we're not
going to increase it by anything so
we're just going to remove that and say
that i
so
[Music]
we can also you know have some
verification to say like
then
let's say
else
we can say else but since this is not
here we can just have a new statement
another else if statement
by saying if user input
is not equals to
rock
or user input
is not equals to
paper
for user input
is not equals to
scissors
then what we want to do
is to print
invalid input
so everything is working perfectly now
it should work perfectly very simple and
basic program let's save this and come
into our terminal
i'm just going to say python 3
python
app.py so what i'm doing is just running
this python app where we built the
program so python 3 python app dot py so
this is the python app.py where we built
this and once i click enter it tells me
to choose so i choose rock
it says your input is wrong the computer
input sees us you win and we can keep
going and say
um
let me choose paper
your input is paper content puts it but
is it tied and if i say exit it's just
gonna stop that and then it's just gonna
opt out of that
so you know it does all of that but one
thing it doesn't do is that it doesn't
print the point so
we are meant to like show it like your
point is this your point is that so
let's say if the user
input exit
will print game ended and then let's
just print
the points
so let's say
you want a point
total
score
off
then we're gonna use concatenation to
add doubt
add that together
and let's just say user points
add that
and say
on the computer
total score
is
let's add the computer score
so once we save this now i'll come back
here and run that again so let's say
paper
and let's say rock so i won that means i
have one point
is it i
know point so it's one zero now and let
me say paypal again
it's a tie again i'll say paper again
computer win so it should be one one
i'll say rock
rock i want to one rock it's a tie so
now if i print exit
says the game ended
and then it gives us an error of not
able to concatenate
integer so what we just need to do is to
come here
and convert that into string before
concatenating them i'm gonna do the same
thing here
paste that
come back in here ronda again now let's
just say rock
rock
rock rock
now let's say exit and it says you want
a total point of three and you come to
one to task
so that works successfully and that is
how we can build a simple
you know console game or terminal game
of rock paper scissors
hi guys we're going to be building a
face detection program using python so
the requirement for this is that you
have
opencv installed so to install these you
just need to come here and type beep
install
opencv iphone python so this command
line is going to install opencv onto
your computer so having this done i
already have it installed so i don't
need to do that again
and then the next thing you need to have
is this
opencv
xml file now this file is pre-written
and then
once we use it in our python code it
will make it far more easier for us to
be able to detect faces using python
so
and then the only thing you just need to
have next is the image you want to
detect so you have an image which will
um which the program will detect the
faces and draw like a rectangle around
the face as it detects
so right here i'm just gonna
go into
my github
and then for my github i can just get
maybe my profile image or something and
then
yep
so open this in new tab
and then i can just drag this into that
yeah and i can rename this to be
[Music]
something like image.jpg or test.jpg
let's name it to be test so now we have
this
then this face detection dot py is a
blank file i'm just going to open that
up in my vs code right here my vs code
you see that i have that file opened up
so right here
the first thing we need to do is to say
import
cv2
now this command
this
line line of code is going to import the
opencv which we installed earlier
and then we need to load the cascade now
the cascade is this xml file which we
have here and then i'm going to link
this xml file in
my github so i'm going to drop a link in
the description below where you can get
this file
so now let's just load that i can say
face underscore cascade
and then that can be goes to cv2
dot cascade classifier
[Music]
and then let's load it up
so
let's just make sure we get experience
correctly
h-a-a-r cascade
so right here cascade
underscore front down face
let's get defaults dot xml
let's
let's check that
h a l cascade underscore for interface
underscore default.xml
so that is correct and then
what we just want to do
is to
import the image also so we can do img
this is the image you want to test
so cv2
that i am read
and then what is the name of that image
test.jpg
so we can say test the jpg
and now that we have that we need to
convert it into a grayscale so the type
of color in which this can read is a
grayscale color and the image is not
grayscale so any image user input we
just want to first of all convert it to
a grayscale color so you can say gray
can be equals to cv2
that's cvt color
and then
convert img
into cv2 that color
on the score
let's say b
g r
yeah
[Music]
to gray
something like yeah this bgr2 gray so
that's what we want to convert it to now
that we've converted it to that color we
just want to detect the faces
so we'll save faces
[Music]
can now be equal to face cascade
dots
detect
multiscale
[Music]
and then
gray
1.1
comma four so this is just what we're
using to detect the faces
now
once we've detected that there's a face
in this picture we just want to draw a
rectangle around that face
so we use a for loop as a 4
x
y
w
h
and faces
[Music]
so cv2 the rectangle
yeah then
img
let's say x comma y
and then
comma
x
plus
w
comma y
plus h
and then outside that we put on that
comma
and say two to five
comma zero
comma zero like this and then
outside that we put on that comma and
just say two
so this is just to draw a rectangle
around those faces
and now let's just display the output so
we can say cv2
dot i am show
now this is just going to show us the
image with
the faces detected
and a rectangle drawn around the faces
and now we can say cv2
dot wait key that means if we press the
key
it should stop showing so you're going
to see that in a minute
so like this yeah
so now let's just add one more line and
say cv2
that i am right
and then we can say
face
detected
[Music]
the jpg
and then we can give it img so now we
can save this
and come here and test that so we can
say python
face underscore detection
why
[Music]
so as you can see
it shows
the image right here with
a rectangle all around the face so that
is how to just build a simple face
detection program using
python
we're going to be building a python
program which is going to send good
morning text messages to a particular
mobile number
every day or every morning so we're
going to give it a particular time in
the morning maybe like 6 a.m or 7 a.m to
send that text and it's automatically
going to do it by itself so for this
program we need two python libraries
these libraries are
text belts
and schedule now text builds is the
library that is going to be handling
sending of the messages now shady is the
library that's going to be handling
when we want this
script or this message to be executed
so let me up over to my browser right
here i have the schedule library opened
on pypi
so as you can see it's pretty
straightforward and easy you just need
to install shadow
and then
i'm going to get back to this in a
second so first of all let's import
shadow
i'm just gonna bring up our terminal
right here
and paste that
so i actually doing
installed already so it should tell me
something like requirements already
satisfied but for you you should go
ahead and install that so let's close
this
so now that we actually do installed
let me talk about the other library
which we're going to be using so let me
go to the website textbelts.com
now this
is like a website
they
they have this platform which allows you
to for sms marketing for
various things right there but they also
have an api which developers can use to
send text messages so
if you use python ruby node.js
javascript there are various languages
right here for this video we're focusing
on python
so as you can see the only thing we need
to access is the api
is just the requests library so without
wasting any time let's pop up our
terminal
and then we're just going to type pip
install
request
so this is just gonna install request on
our machine so i have it installed it
says requirement ready satisfied
so now that we have all of these
let's just get started with the coding
so as you can see this is the basic code
to just send a text message
so what we just need is the url which
they've given us here
and the phone number the message and the
key so
as you can see we're posting a
particular
some particular data
to this url so this key
they have this demo key which is text
built so that key allows you to send
message for free but once a day so if
you want to have unlimited access then
you have to go for your paid plan but
for this video i'm just showing you how
to use this we're going to be sticking
with this text belt key
so
let's go back to our code
so the phone number which we're going to
be sending this message is my personal
phone number so i have it stored right
here in this credentials or p wifi i
have my phone number stored as a
variable right there just for security
reasons so i don't show it here so the
first thing i want to do is to import
the mobile number so let's say from
credentials
imports
mobile
number so now that i have that imported
i'm just gonna dive straight into the
coding so i'll say import requests
so now that request
is the library we're gonna be using to
send data to text build
so now we're just going to have our
function which is going to basically
send message
and we don't want to give it any
parameter we don't need to
and then we can just have a simple
variable named rasp
which will be equal to requests
dot post
then we can say http
so now this is the
text built website in which was sending
or posting our data
so say text build
dot com
and slash text
so now we're just going to say the phone
number
which is phone
should be this mobile number which we
imported so say it's mobile number
and then the next thing we need to give
it is the message
[Music]
so you can just say the message
is
[Music]
a good morning
so that's the message
and then the key as i explained earlier
why is in the
demo key the free key
so the key is text built
now we have all this set up let's make
sure we put a comma right here
we have all these
and then right here we just want to
print
rest
does json
so we want to print the result as in in
the json format basically
so now we have this
code done so this code on its own if i
run it it's just going to execute this
function and then send me
this message
a good morning
to my mobile number but that's not what
we want to do in this video that's not
the main purpose the main purpose is to
show you how to schedule this particular
function
so
let's quickly go back to the shadow page
right here
now you can see that it's pretty easy
and straightforward to use these all we
just need to do is to import schedule
and time
and then the function which we want to
say do which we already have right here
and then we just need to know the time
we want to schedule it to
so that's very easy
now
let's import shadow
and then let's import time
so now we have these imported and then
the next thing we just need to do
down below our function
we can just say shadow
so we want to schedule it to be
for every morning so save dot every
downside dot d
[Music]
don't say dots
so day
dot at
so we want to schedule it for every
morning
at a particular time so right here we
should have this curly braces that's
because it's like a method like a
function which we are using
so we are saying schedule.day
but
every.day.
so right here
this ad is the time in the day we want
to share delays for so
let's say
um 6 00 am so 0 6
a.m so we don't write am right here what
we do is just write it in the 24 hour
clock so if it's 6 p.m we need to put
this at 18 000
6 a.m 0 6
so now that we have that we just say dot
do
then
right here we're passing the function
which we want to run
so say send message
so now i would like to run this now but
if i run this now obviously this is
going to send me a message at six am
tomorrow
so first of all let's comment this out
and then let's run this like every 10
seconds so it's gonna do right now
so we can just simply say just for the
testing
we can say [ __ ] do
that every
10
seconds
don't do
and obviously we want to do send message
so that's the code to do that
so for every 10 seconds is basically do
this
function
and then we must not forget to add our
while loop so it continues the loop so
every day every minute every second
continues to loop
so say while true
should do dot run
pending yeah that's it
and then
time
let's give it to sleep
just one one is fine
so now this is ready let's quickly go
through recap on what we did so we
imported the phone number the request
schedule and time
then we add the function which does
everything
and then right here we just shared dude
when this function should be executed
and then we made sure we added the loop
so now let's run this and test it out
so let me pop up this terminal
right here you can see that it is
running
so we should give it like 10 seconds
because right here we said 10 seconds
so in 10 seconds it should
have
executed so right here it says success
false
arrow out of quota quota remaining 0.
now this error just saying that this
text belt key
right here has been used for the day so
i used this when i was testing it today
so that's basically how to do that as
you can see it's running every 10
seconds every 10 seconds as i said this
key you can only use it once a day
so um
obviously
i have used it today i guess that's why
but again
if we
make sure we come here
text builds
okay so it is text built and we wrote
text built so
um i should love that
done already because i have used it
today but let's see
so
it might work it might not work 50 50
chance let's see let's go
um
maybe i should quit this
quit and then run again so now
fingers crossed
let's give it 10 seconds
one
two
three
four
okay
you should do any minute
so still the same things test text are
temporarily disabled so c show does the
same thing that
temporarily they've disabled
test text so it's running every 10
seconds yeah that is done so there are
other libraries instead of using text
but you can use twilio you can use
basically
plenty of stuffs but i just showed you
how to use this schedule library that
was the main purpose of this video to
schedule a task now you can see it's
doing every 10 seconds and here you want
it
hey guys what's up we're going to be
talking about web scraping with python
so web scraping is basically just
getting or extracting data from a
website so when we say web scripting web
stands for website scripting stands for
you know extracting or getting some
information from that website so that's
basically the concept of web scraping
so this can come in handy sometimes
is popularly used in python and i'm
going to show you how to do that in this
video
so i have my website here called ritomi
my blog website
and what i want to do is i want to
scrape
all the names of blog posts i have on my
website i can scrape everything
or i can just only get the first name or
anything i want to get
so how web scraping works is that
we're gonna send a request from our code
we're gonna send a request to that url
which we want to script and then we're
gonna get a response back which the data
would need
so
before we get started we need two python
libraries these libraries are requests
and beautiful soup
now request is used for sending requests
and beautiful soup is used for filtering
the data we need specifically
so let's go ahead and install these
libraries say peep
install
ps4
which is beautiful soup
and say pip
and store requests
so as you can see the both gives me
uh
requirement already satisfied that's
because i already have it installed
so now let's just go into our python
shell
right here we just need to import
requests
and then after that we need to import
beautiful soup so say from bs4
import beauty for
soup
so now that we have those two imported
this url which we want to send the
request to we need to specify it in a
variable say url equals to
[Music]
so now we have the url want to send the
request to so let's go ahead and send
the request
so say r
equals to request
[Music]
dots gets
to this url
so
now we've sent a request to that url
if i put r and hit enter
it says response 200. now when it says
200 means the request was sent
successfully and we've gotten a response
that means everything is okay but we
have another one or any other number it
means an error
so now that we know that everything is
good
let's just use beautiful soup to get the
data we need
so first of all we have to do soup
equals to
beautiful
soup
open brackets
add.content
comma
we'll put lxml to pass it well
and we hit enter so now this has passed
what we need
what we want to do now is to get the
name of this
how will we know this so now we need to
know the html tag this belongs in is
it's in an h1 tag using a p tag is in a
div tag
first to do this we'll make sure we're
on what we need
we right click on it
scroll down and hit inspect
so now you can see that it is
on that title which i need
and as you can see it's in an h2 tag
with a class of post title so let's tell
our python code and that's what we are
looking for so let's say title
should be equals to
soup now this is the soup
dot find underscore all
find all
find the one with an h2 tag
which has
a class of post title
[Music]
post
title
now let's close this
now
let me just print title
you can see i have
a list of html code the first one
is how to deploy a django project to
hiroku the second one is best way to get
started with django the third one is how
to create a bitcoin wallet and on and on
and on but all these are just html codes
now i can just print only the text i
don't want to print them with their a
tag or their h2 tag i just want only the
text
i can just say title dot get text
[Music]
so now it says there's an attribute
error so anytime we are using the get
text we must make sure that we're only
getting one
so
anytime i using that does get text
mechanism for a list
we can only use it for when we are
getting let's say only the
number nine or the number four or the
first one
so
now
we can just say titu
[Music]
let's get the first one
type to zero
dot get text
now you see it says how to deploy jungle
project to uroku it gives me only the
text but we still have this and and this
that's because we didn't put it in a
variable now let's say we add it in a
variable and say uh
tie to one equals to
tie two
zero
dot get text
[Music]
now when i print title one
[Music]
you can now see that it just gave me
what i need how to deploy a jungle
project to iroku
which is what we have right here
but right here you can see that we had
an error where was that
when we said title.gettext
when i said you can only use it for one
now we have another way which can use
which is a for loop so we can do
something like four
c
in
site2
dot get text or team title
we can do something like
print c dot get text
[Music]
so as you can see using a for loop it
automatically gives us only the text of
every single thing
that's because we used a for loop you
can see only the text now we don't have
any other html code
with it it gives us a list of
all of it
but now i'm sure you might be having a
question that i thought we only getting
the first one and then we add only the
html code for this first one
then why is it giving us a list of
everything
so the reason why
when we told html we wanted this code
and instead of giving us only this code
it gave us everything is because
each of these is inside the same tag so
now you can see h2
class post title if i come here i'll
come to the second one you see it's also
in h2 with a class of post title but do
the same with third one is in h2 with
the class of po title so that's what it
does it's just gonna get a list of
everything correlating to the data you
gave it to find
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
how to resize an image using python
to do this we're going to use a
particular library called pillow
so you need to make sure you have pillow
installed but before we even get into
coding let's quickly write the steps
that we're going to take to do this
so first we're going to have to
install pillow
if you haven't
then
we're going to import pillow of course
after importing pillow what we just need
to do is to open up the image
the image we want to resize
it's in python so we use a particular
code to open up that image
then
what we can just do let's say we want to
print the size the current
size
of that image so the user knows the
current size then once we print the
current size we want to specify
the size we want to change it to
change it to
then once we specify that we just save
save the new
resized
image
so this is literally all we need to do
is pretty straight forward and pretty
quick
so first of all let's open up a terminal
to install pillow so what you need to do
is to type pip3 and as i always say if
you're on a windows just type pip if
you're on a mac type pip3
install
pillow and notice that i used caps later
here it has to be calculator
for p once i hit enter i already have it
installed so it says recommend already
satisfied but for you if you just go
ahead and install that
so let's close that terminal we can
leave those comments there so we'll
follow it
so to import pillow since this is done
i just hit done the next thing you want
to do is to import pillow that is easy
what we just need to do is to say from
pil
import
image
so
pil alone is pillow that's what we've
imported but for this particular thing
we want to do
for the resizing we need this image so
that's why we're importing image from
pillow we don't need the whole module we
just need this image
so once we have that let's update this
and say done next we want to do is open
the image you want to resize so to open
the image we're going to use image.open
so let's say image is equals to
image dot
open so i'm
having a new variable named image this
is where i'm going to store the opened
image and i'm using this image module
here and i'm saying image.open
and then we're going to specify the name
of the
picture that we want to open so right
here i have this picture named code with
tomi logo so i'm just going to copy the
whole name
and i'm going to come back in here
and i'm going to paste that in there so
that is going to open up that image and
store it in this variable so that is
also done
the next thing we want to do is to
print the current size of the image so
to do this we're just going to say print
and let's do something like
f
current size
so we can say the image size
image which is this image dot size that
is just going to print the current size
for us is that easy
we can actually test this so let's
run it and see so as you can see it says
176 to 176 that is the current size
let's actually test that and see if that
is correct so we come back in here
we right click and click on get info
so let's see right here as you can see
in dimensions it says that that is 176
by one sentences so that is pretty
accurate
so once we have that done we know the
current size so now we can know what we
want to change it to
so let's see let's say
resized
image
so this resize image is the variable
which we're going to store the new the
size of the new image so we're going to
change this image to let's say 500 by
500 so to do this we're going to say
image
dot resize
we just want to say
we are going to have two brackets in
here 500
by 500 so this is going to resize the
image to 500 by 500 but we are not done
this just like specifies what we want to
change but it doesn't actually save it
so to save it we're going to say resized
image
dot save
so now we're going to specify the name
of the new file so let's say
code with
tommy
logo
let's say 500.jpg
so we're going to save it as a jpeg file
let's see jpeg same thing but let's just
leave it like that so
this is actually what we need is just
like one two three four five five lines
of code that we need to actually change
this so let's save this file
let's run it
it shows us the current size it doesn't
say anything but if we come back in here
you're going to see that we now have a
new
picture
being saved they are being created here
name code we told me logo 500 which is
actually what we specified right here
called ritomi logo 500
now if we right click it and get the
info the information you can see now it
says the dimension of this image is 500
by 500 so this is how you can you know
this with python so there are various
ways you can even actually implement
this in like a real project imagine you
have a you can you have a user that
wants to you know come to your website
and you know upload an image and change
an image to whatever size they want they
can easily do that with
using this program so you can actually
let's say build a web app that does that
takes an image and tells the user to
input the size they want to you know
change it to and then you give them the
image or let's say you give them a link
to the new resized image so let's
actually do something like that let's
ask the user what they want we'll put
this in a function and let's see what
that does so we can say dev
resize
image
and this is going to collect
is actually going to have two different
parameters so
size one let's just say that
size two i guess
and what this is doing is collecting the
pixel
dimensions so we're going to tap this
so what this is just going to do now so
it's going to open this image right
print the current size and then instead
of saying this we're going to say size 1
and size two
change that to two and let's just say
what we can even do right here we can
just do something like
you know this
use concatenation
and we can just say
size one
and then you know to have that's the
name of the image so now we can call
this function
resize image
but to give it the you know the
parameters it needs instead of just
giving it like you know with 2 200 by
you know 300 what we want to do is to
ask the user so we can just say
um
print
no we want to say
size one
equals
input
enter length
enter width
and for size 2
we can say entirely
then we're going to call this function
using this size one
and size two
so this actually makes it quite more
interactive so now let's see what that
gives us
we run this
entire wave so let's say i want to
change to 2 000
uh by
40
weird dimension but let's see
so it
actually gives us an error it says
string cannot be interpreted as integer
that is right here so what we need to do
is to just make sure that we are
changing this input into an integer
because it sees it as a string as
default
so we're just gonna do this integer
whatever the user inputs want to change
it to an integer
so let's save that you can either change
it to an integer here or you can just do
the same thing by changing it to an
integer right here like this so that's
the same thing but we already changed it
there so it should work now
let's run this 2000
by 40
so it gives us an error and says can
only concatenate string not integer so
also when we're you know dealing with
concatenation you can add us because it
sees this as an integer right so you can
add an integer on the string so what you
need to do now you need to change this
back to a string right here
where we're concatenating and that
should solve it
so let's run it again now
and this should work perfectly two
thousand by forty gives us the current
size
right here and if we come back in here
we're gonna see that we have probably
twenty two thousand
weird looking image when we get the info
you can see that we have two thousand by
forty
now this is how you can resize an image
with python
in this tutorial i'm gonna be showing
you how to draw a chat or graph with
python
so this is quite straightforward because
we're going to be using a library called
matplotlib so
we first of all have to install the
library and to do this is quite easy
what we just need to do is to open up
the terminal
and install it like we installed all the
other ones so pip free
install
mat plot
lib
so i have installed of course it says
recommend already satisfied but for you
you should go ahead and install that if
you don't have it installed so once we
have this installed the next thing we
need to do is to just import it so we're
going to import matplotlib
pie plot
so what we need is dot pi plot let's put
it as plt so we don't need to type this
every single time we just type plt when
we need it
so the first thing we want to do now is
to determine the x axis so in a graph
right we have the x-axis and we have the
y-axis the x-axis is the horizontal
y-axis is the vertical so we want to
determine the points for the x-axis to
do this we can just say x and we're
going to specify that as a list so let's
just say something like 2
2
4 5
and we're going to do the same thing for
the y axis
and let's say something like
2 also
but then three
six so that is all right so what this is
this are coordinates so this is the
first coordinates two two
four by three and five and six so these
are coordinates are corresponding to
themselves so on the graph there will be
a point where 2 is equals to 2 4
corresponds to 3 and 5 corresponds to 6.
i'm going to show you that and so let's
plot the point to plot the point we're
going to say plt
dot plot
comma y
so this is going to plot the point but
then we want to name the x axis so it's
going to have a name so to do this we're
going to say plt.x
label
so
let's say
x axis
we're going to do the same thing for the
y axis so we'll say plt
dot y label
and let's say this is
y-axis
and what we just need to do is give you
a title let's say plc
the title is pretty easy and
straightforward so we can just say
demo graph
and what we just need to do nice to just
show you so everything has been plotted
successfully we just need to show it by
saying plt dot show
so this is going to show us the graph
and once i click on run
it's gonna open up as you can see it
opened up this
particular window and as you can see
right here we specified let me quit this
real quick two and two
okay i quit that so that quit let's
run that again
so let's make this large you can see
that this has two by two this has four
and three and this has five and six just
like what we did
here two by two four and three five and
six so we can play with that a little
bit and we can even add more points and
say something like
one
i will say four
now we can let's say
um one six
and yeah also let's say one
seven so let's run that and see what
that gives us
so as you can see it's kind of a weird
graph because that's go and come back
but you can see what i'm talking about
as all the points correspond to
themselves and what we gave them right
here
so to actually avoid that weird error
what we can just is to remove this one
so we don't go back
in descending order so we just go
forward once i save this and try to run
it again
we should have another pop-up
let's quit this
and then run that again
so as you can see now we have a normal
graph so that is how to do that pretty
easy pretty straightforward as you can
see everything works successfully we can
actually build like a full blown web
application just for this like or even
build an api just on this just providing
this type of service to a user so that
is the first
stuff i'm going to show you in here we
can also do
another stuff by like adding two
different lines on one graph so for us
to do this what we just need to do is to
say let's say this is x1
y1
and what we're just going to say
is
right here we say plt.plot we're going
to say x1 y1 so this is the first line
on the graph we'll say label let's label
this
line one
so what we want to do now is do exactly
the same thing again but now i'm going
to say x2 y2 so x2
and let's give x2 one two three four
five let's just make it a normal linear
graph and we're going to say y2
and let's just say one two three four
so that is that and what we're going to
do now is to plot that line also so i
want to plot that line on the graph so
hit play lt.plot
i want to plot x2
y2 i want to give this a label of line
two
so once we have that the next thing that
we just need to do
since we already plotted the first line
and then we've plotted the second line
is now easier because we can just say
prt.x label to actually plot this so
this plt is like an instance of this
particular
you know pi plots that we imported just
so you know that so what we need to do
now is to come here and say
plt dot x label x axis we already have
that we already have the y axis we have
the title the only thing we want to add
is called legend so i'm going to explain
what that is so let's just say demograph
two lines
so we're going to add legend and what
this legend does is that it shows an
indication for the two different lines
with different colors so it's going to
tell you what color is what line and
what what color is the other line so
let's say plt.legend
so this is going to show that and i'm
going to show you what that is when it
shows so this is what we need just
ignore this error because i'm sure like
the library hasn't updated or something
but everything is working now let's run
this and see so as you can see we have
two different you know lines
and this is what i mean by legend if i
make this large this legend is actually
indicating what line is what color so
line one is the blue one and line two is
the orange one so as you can see we have
here y axis x-axis demograph two lines
we can even save this by clicking on
this button right here it's going to
save as an image on your computer
so let's come back here and let's quit
this there are also various things we
can still do for example we can you know
like have point on each graph like where
we have plt.plot so let's actually
remove
these two lines we don't want to plot
two let's just have one
and we don't really need legend since we
don't have two
so what we want to do right here now is
that where we have plt.plot
what we can just say
let's remove x1 y1 let's just change it
to x and y
so what we can just say right here is to
have
color so i'm going to show you what
we're doing because it's better to you
know show you the image
so let's say the color is green
line style
line style
is equal to dashed
and we have line width
and let's just say line which is equals
to three
we have marker
is equals to
o we have
marker
face color
and let's say this is um let's say blue
and
marker size
marker size
is equals to 12. so we don't
let's remove
this
so we removed that and what we just want
to do is to come here
what we're just going to do is to say
plt
dot
y
name so while basically selecting the
x and y ranges
so we're gonna do
one
two eight
and plt
dot
x limb
and we're gonna do
one to a also
and then right here we're just gonna
have the label which we already have
there we're gonna have tie two
so let's just change this to demographic
let's say customization
so we're just customizing what we need
and then let's just say plt.show so once
we run this you see the changes
so as you can see this is all we have
you can see that when we specify this
line as blue
if i bring this down a little bit
you can see that that marker face color
is blue and line style is dashed so as
you can see line style is dash and the
color of that line is green the color is
green the face
this right here face color is blue so
basically that's what all of that does
is just some pretty cool customization
that you might want to add to your graph
so let's just go ahead and quit this
so now we've been
dealing with the normal graphs what we
want to do is to actually i'm going to
show you how to draw a bar chart so to
draw a bar chart is also pretty easy
what you just need to do
so let's just change this to left
and let's say this is height
and let's give this like
one two three four five
and let's give this like
something like
10
11
23
36
and 4.
so this is the height of the bars
right in a bar chart and this is the x
coordinate of the left
side of the bars
and let's give it
label for each of the bars so what we're
going to do is to just say
tick label
label
is equals to
let's say
one
two
we have to put all of these as strings
so want two
three
four
and let's say five
and once we have all of this we can now
say plt dot bar
since we're doing a bacha so i'm going
to give it left
height
tick label
equal stick label
and then we want to say with i want to
specify the width
as no point a
let's say color
let's give the color something like
blue
and orange
so that's going to do the work for us
and what we just want to do is to we
don't need this we don't need plots what
we need was ba
so now we don't also don't need this
we're just going to say is the x label
which is x axis right y-axis and let's
say demograph bar chart
and let's now show it so that is all we
need so you can see everything we did
here pretty easy
now once we run this we should have a
bar chart shown as you can see beautiful
we have one two three four five other
names x-axis y-axis
demograph bar chart that is how to
easily you know create a bar chart in
python it's very easy and you know very
straightforward
you can also do more things like scatter
graph you know pie chart and all of that
but i feel like if you really want to go
into this you can also research more on
this particular library but for now this
is how to you know let's run that again
this is how to build
a simple program that
you know automatically generate graphs
giving some figures